okay I have something truly special for
you today I'm gonna play a three-minute
clip of Mike Pence speaking now please
don't - now don't turn this I know that
that's disgusting but there's a reason
for this
normally I don't play three-minute clips
on the show normally we cut them up I
play a little segment I analyze it so on
and so forth
playing the full three minutes here is
critical to understanding the anatomy of
not answering a question Mike Pence
vice-president was interviewed on Fox
and Friends yesterday morning and Brian
Kilmeade asks a very straightforward
question the question Brian asked is is
it harder for someone who is black to
make it in the United States today in
2020 very straightforward question Mike
Pence talked for three minutes but said
absolutely nothing that could count as
an answer so let's just watch it's three
minutes sit through it I apologize
but pay close attention to what Mike
Pence says because you will notice that
he actually doesn't say anything about
the question that he was asked to for
someone who's black to make it in this
country whether they're man or woman do
you think it's harder for them to make
it in this country in 2020 well Brian I
love your question because I saw where a
Joe Biden last night actually tweeted
that everybody ought to have a fair shot
at the American dream and it's one of
the reasons why as the president and I
we're talking as the president spoke in
Dallas last week he's made it clear that
while we're going to take a step today
to provide new resources to law
enforcement to help them you know
embrace higher standards on
de-escalation and the use of force and
and and have an established in
information sharing I mean you know as I
said nobody hates bad cops more than
good cops and most of the men and women
who put on the uniform of law
enforcement every day are really the
best of us we know that so we're going
to take these steps today to help
improve policing to help to move that
process forward as a country in the wake
of these tragic events and the violence
that ensued
but we're not going to stop there
I mean if Biden says everybody ought to
have a fair shot at the American dream
well we would say well well why don't
you support allowing african-american
families to choose where their kids go
to school I mean this president has
actually stood strong for school choice
we've doubled the educational choice
program here in our nation's capital and
we really do believe that that you
shouldn't you shouldn't be denied the
ability to choose where your kids go to
school just because of your zip code or
because of your income we also as you
said under this president's policies we
had the lowest unemployment level ever
recorded for African Americans we worked
with senator Tim Scott to to enact
Opportunity Zones now there's more than
4,000 Opportunity Zones that have
attracted a hundred billion dollars of
investment into our cities we're going
to continue to drive forward on jobs and
opportunity I mean we understand that
the media narrative around this time and
the negativity around this time but as
as I sat down with african-american
leaders in Pittsburgh in Maryland as the
president welcomed leaders here to the
into the White House and in Dallas I
think I think millions of African
Americans saw the progress that we were
making over the last three years and
they know as we bring this economy back
in the wake of not just these tragic
events and the end of violence that
ensued but in the wake of course of this
coronavirus pandemic that its president
Donald Trump who has the prescription
for more prosperity more educational
opportunity and in really more access to
the American Dream than 50 years of
Democrat leadership under the likes of
Joe Biden has ever given them okay so to
remind you what the question was because
you might have forgotten while Mike
Pence was rambling the question was is
it harder for black people to make it in
the United States today it's really a
question that goes to systemic racism
not about individuals but about systems
and Mike Pence doesn't even come close
to even talking about it Mike Pence's
answer was to criticize Joe Biden
to talk about giving law enforcement
more resources to talk about good cops
dislike bad cops to remind us that most
cops are good he brought up this tired
school choice talking point which we'll
get to later pence mentions we had low
black unemployment and he worked with a
black guy named Tim Scott I'm gonna come
back to that the media is being very
negative
he said I've spoken to black people
Trump knows how to bring prosperity to
people and Democrats are bad so Mike
Pence said ten different things during
those three minutes none of which are
answers to the questions so now let's go
back briefly to black unemployment
unemployment is was really low before
the virus remember how during Barack
Obama's presidency Republicans insisted
there are more people than ever not
working in the United States and then
the day Donald Trump became president
the same Republicans were saying we have
more people than ever working in the
United States the explanation for that
talking point was or is the population
keeps growing so at most times it is
true that we have more people working
than ever before and more people not
working than ever before similarly with
this low black unemployment talking
point that Trump and pence love to use
when unemployment is low it's generally
low for all groups again unless some
group is particularly unaffected by
things going well overall there was
nothing special that Donald Trump did
for black Americans that would lower
their unemployment rate relative to
other groups unemployment was just low
for for everybody until coronavirus hit
so now we get to the real question Brian
Kilmeade after which is there an
interesting question is it tougher to
make it if you were black in the United
States for me the clearest way to think
about this is would I want to switch to
being black or brown right now would I
be better off would I have been better
off growing up if I had been black or
brown and the answer is of course not of
course not because I know that if I were
black or brown I would be treated
differently and I would not be better
off today we all know it in fact
I don't even have to think about the
hypothetical of being black I can think
about something much more tangible I'm
an immigrant from Argentina I learned
English when I was five moved to the
United States
I have very white skin if I and my
parents moved to the u.s. not as white
Hispanic folks but as black
I'm sorry brown Hispanic folks I think
would be the way to say it I would have
been treated differently from the moment
we got here my parents would have been
treated differently from the moment that
we got here and despite having made big
progress when it comes to race in the
United States and we have I don't deny
that I know that we would have been
worse off now by the way I don't often
hear people on the Left say this the
United States is definitely less racist
than many other countries I've been to a
lot of places in the world and lots of
them are more racist than the United
States often these are places that are
much more homogeneous and less diverse
than the United States the u.s. is not
as far as I'm concerned the most racist
country that's not actually at issue
here the point is we have the resources
to do way better and we still have major
problems with race and the answer to
Brian Kilmeade question to Mike Pence is
of course it's tougher to make it in the
United States in 2020 if you are black
or brown that still is the case and Mike
Pence managing to spit out three minutes
worth of words while saying nothing at
all about what he was asked about nor do
VPN one of our sponsors is giving you
70% off a three year plan which is just
a little over three bucks a month and
you'll get an extra month free when you
go to Nord bpn com slash David Pakman or
go to their website use the coupon code
David Pakman if you don't use a VPN now
is the time to start I always use a VPN
on my computer and my phone it makes you
totally anonymous when you're browsing
online you won't be spied on websites
can't track you around the internet your
data is safe from hackers and Nord VPN
is the one you want to go with because
they don't keep records on your internet
history they double encrypt your data
their servers are super fast and they
provide unlimited bandwidth Nord VP
is giving you 70% off a three-year plan
that's just over three bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
Nordby pn dot-com slash david pakman
I've put a link right underneath the
video or just go to their website and
use the coupon code david pakman